Speaker 1: As we reported to you yesterday,
Donald Trump's Facebook ban has been reduced
from indefinite to we will review it in six
months.
But it was not ended yesterday for anybody
thinking Trump might be back on Facebook yesterday.
From that perspective, the ban was extended
as expected.
Republicans.
Fox News right wing media Don Jr., even Donald
Trump himself from his new blog, have been
melting down over this decision.
We're going to go through it and we're going
to point out what are some really, truly terrible
arguments so that you will be prepared when
you hear these or see these on Facebook or
at the WaterCooler, our water coolers, even
covid safe.
Now, I don't know.
First, Donald Trump himself, who published
to his new communications social media platform,
which I know as a as a blog, he published
the following message.
This is Trump.
What Facebook, Twitter and Google have done
is a total disgrace and an embarrassment to
our country.
Now, he's wrong about that.
The embarrassment are the actions of Trump
that led to his being banned, including inciting
a riot on January 6th. Trump goes on to say,
Free speech has been taken away from the president
of the United States because the radical left
lunatics are afraid of the truth.
But the truth will come out anyway, bigger
and stronger than ever before.
This is not really a free speech issue, and
we've talked about that before and we'll talk
about it in a minute.
So I won't spend too much time on that.
Trump then going on to say the people of our
country will not stand for it.
These corrupt social media companies must
pay a political price and must never again
be allowed to destroy and decimate our electoral
process.
I don't know what kind of a price Trump is
talking about a political price like maybe
regulation which Trump is against.
Next example here is Donald Trump's former
chief of staff, Mark Meadows, on Fox News
saying that it is a sad day for America and
this might actually make Republicans in Congress
enforce the antitrust laws already on the
books that they never cared about until now.
This is just the best.
Take a look
Speaker 4: at the oversight board will uphold
the ban on Donald Trump.
Your reaction?
Yeah, it's a sad day for America.
It's a sad day for Facebook, because I can
tell you a number of members of Congress are
now looking at do they break up Facebook?
Do they make sure that they don't have a monopoly?
And I can tell you that it's two different
standards, one for Donald Trump and one for
a number of other people that are on their
sites and suggesting that more nefarious things
than what the president has been accused of
actually go unnoticed often.
And so this is a sad day for America, but
a Saturday for the the Facebook's of the world
who have actually enjoyed a very wild, Wild
West kind of regulatory environment.
I can tell you that's going to change.
The discussion will happen within hours of
this decision on Capitol Hill, just a few
blocks from where I am now.
Speaker 1: There is a real conversation here
about the reality that the United States has
had anti-trust laws on the books for a long
time.
There has been no interest in the US politically
in enforcing them.
I've been talking about this issue for years.
We've done interviews about it.
The Republicans never cared before about enforcing
antitrust.
Antitrust enforcement is regulation, which
they are against suddenly.
Now, these hypocrites care about antitrust.
They are transparently pathetic.
The next clip I would play would be of Donald
Trump Jr. on Stephen Crowder's program.
From what I understand, Crowder is really
aggressive with copyright strikes on YouTube.
So I'm not going to play the clip.
But as Crowder tweeted, Don Junior told him
that, quote, The Facebook oversight board
holding up the Trump suspension says a lot
about the powers of companies like Facebook.
I imagine the board doesn't have a lot of
people who share our views.
It's an echo chamber of Silicon Valley now.
Same thing.
Again, they suddenly care about antitrust
now that they think it would help them to
enforce it.
But they never cared for decades about all
of the monopolistic behavior that could have
been stopped by enforcing the laws already
on the books.
Next clip is from Newsmax.
Here is Susan.
Right.
Susan is a Trump endorsed Republican candidate
for Congress.
Listen to what she says.
Speaker 4: This obviously making waves with
so many conservative voices here as they felt
silenced along the way.
And this ban speaks volumes.
Your thoughts on it when you saw that breaking
news?
Speaker 5: Well, I haven't read nearly as
much about it as as I will, of course, throughout
the day, but I will tell you that this the
censorship that the tech giants are engaging
in is outrageous.
It is absolutely outrageous.
I don't support it.
I think that, you know, you have to really
wonder who who is making these decisions.
It's very subjective.
There's some things they censor and some things
they don't.
There's a lot of radical groups on Facebook
and other social media platforms who don't
seem to be censored at all.
But conservative groups and conservative voices
are continually censored, continually pushed
back and continually vilified in Congress.
I'll do everything I can to to shut that effort
down and and push back on them as well.
Speaker 1: She hasn't read about it, but it's
definitely censorship.
Who is making these decisions?
For profit companies that Republicans like
you, Susan Wright, have said for the last
hundred years should should never be regulated
and should be allowed to make whatever decisions
they want.
That's who's making the decisions.
Just another painfully hypocritical troll.
And by the way, censorship of conservative
voices on Facebook.
The top clips on Facebook almost every day
are Ben Shapiro, Dan Bongino, Sean Hannity,
other Fox News clips, other Fox News host.
It's almost all right wingers that dominate
the top clips on Facebook.
Last one.
Republican Congressman Peter King says this
violates free speech.
Take a
Speaker 5: listen.
Congressman King, we'll start with you.
Your reaction to this ruling by Facebook to
uphold the ban for President Trump, at least
temporarily.
Speaker 3: I think it's unfortunate we even
have to discuss this.
I think it's outrageous what Facebook has
done.
And I would say the same with Bernie Sanders
or Hillary Clinton to me, whether or not there's
a constitutional right and it could be a legal
right here because of all the legal benefits
and coverages and the exemptions for that
Congress has given to these platforms and
Facebook and Twitter.
But I first of all, I think Facebook is wrong.
It's going to be his own platform that's going
to work.
I just think Congress has to look at this.
I think this is analogous to we had in the
beginning of the last century when anti-trust
assured consumers can make a choice but got
a real choice because you have a few
Speaker 1: and there it is.
Consumers can make a choice, but it's not
a real choice and it's a free speech issue
and it's time to enforce antitrust.
What a principled statement from Peter King.
Right.
Do not fall for it.
It's only about how does it affect them right
now?
That's all that this is about.
Every single one of these arguments hypocritically
and obviously not an argument they made until
they thought we got to get Trump back on Twitter
and Facebook.
And all of a sudden these are the arguments
they're not making.
Don't
fall
for it.